do you ever like on the show dr. can do
have you ever attempted to incorporate
mr. Chau or have mr. Chau you leave you
like dr. ken leaves the room and then
MIT and then mr. Chau visits yeah yeah
oh honey my my cousin the international
criminal Leslie Chow is coming over to
the pool but you
[Applause]
the Bradys screen yeah you know you
could go on other shows too yeah I could
I could go on like Game of Thrones
I could go well yeah mr. Chau should
show up on all the I should show up on
Game of Thrones
I really don't know that show very well
but if the child did go oh like boobies
and hilltops you should go on Empire
actually go on Empire yeah tchau on
Empire would be total ooh Terrence
Howard I don't know my problem taraji P
Hansen I'm gonna make all these shows
yeah I think he's a good fixer-upper in
all these shows if if cousin Oliver if
you will of all this if mf'er isn't at
the end of the sentence I think he loses
a lot of his potency yeah he seems like
you gotta throw that in at the end of
everything guys you gotta put my brand
otherwise